breaking news alert
we start here at 6 30 with some breaking
news a pedestrian has been killed and
police right now are searching for the
driver who hit that individual roads
closed right now on the valley's west
side near sahara and jones which is
where hector mejia is live this morning
with the latest hector good morning to
you
good morning and just in the last few
minutes investigators removed the
victim's body from the eastbound travel
lanes of sahara right behind us metro
police say the pedestrian was crossing
the intersection when they were killed
by a hit and run driver right now both
directions of sahara remain closed
between jones and torrey pines this
happened around 1 30 this morning right
now no detailed description for the
suspect's vehicle yet police believe the
car was traveling eastbound on sahara
struck the victim at the intersection
with el camino and left police believe
the suspect kept driving eastbound on
sahara and back out here again the
closure still in effect right now expect
traffic delays in the area while police
remain on the scene here we have live
team coverage for you this morning let's
send it back over to nate tannenbaum
who's handling traffic hey there nate
our